pas 400 francs d'accord d'accord et je
termine avec ceux ci
qu est ce si c'est un attelage une boule
d'attelage qu'est ce qui se passe à
l'heure actuelle c'est que la boule
d'attelage une fois qu'elle est montée
et bien pour la démonter faut prendre
des outils faut prendre toutes sortes de
choses et c'est extrêmement pénible ça
ferait remarquer adultes du tout oui à
dents et on s'était dit ça serait bien
de pouvoir la démonter cette goutte à ce
qu'on s'en sert pas tout le temps c'est
pas tout le temps à ces lois et lordon
est l'intérêt c'est que pour l'instant
vous ne pouviez pas le faire surtout
pour cent c'est en général que deux
trois fois par an alors voilà maintenant
c'est possible
en fait les chinois il ya anti anti
système avec une clé qui vous permet de
la clip c'est sans aucun problème
alors qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est
pas commercialisé encore est le seul
inconvénient c'est qu'il faut quand même
avoir le système d'attaché
non y'a quoi j'ai fait beau est-ce qu'il
ya par terre on en parlera des passes et
que ça nous arrangerait la macbu la ba
écoute ta poule a derrière lui marc je
propose pour nous remettre de nos
émotions d'aller à la cuisine en valeur
joindre le mondial d'après midi allez
c'est parfaitement clair qu'au pire à
celle de la terre et manuel laporte
bombe à nos jours